[Musique]
deux guerriers naguère se faisait
naguère je tuerai pour un mac et ont pu
m'en alors qu'il est en toi petit
quelque chose
les frères grandir séparément jusqu'à
atteindre un âge critique la quarantaine
baba s complète et bientôt noël cette
année mon lapin parfois les gens se
perdent de vue
mme allende
on peut pas tout arrangé avec du fric
bien sûr que c'était mon cas pas changé
du tout tu es toujours un gros bébé
c'est cela des droits sera décapitée
excusez moi ça m'ennuie d'interrompre
une conversation si captivante mais
pourquoi financier pas une chacun
[Musique]
elle sait parler et beaucoup j'ai
reprend l affaire de famille
et maintenant vous bossez pour nous
aller boomeur baby corp a conçu un
nouveau là qui peut transformer un
adulte un bébé pendant 48 heures tu veux
que je redevienne un bébé ça c'est l'âge
ingrat baby corp assure à l'effacement
total de la mémoire après cette
expérience
alors quel est le problème un génie du
mal à apprend aux enfants à être de très
très vilain bd bienvenue à la révolution
des bébés on va nous falloir un
déguisement pour nous un fil très
sérieux on va faire quoi de la voile aux
nounous
merci d'être toujours là pour me couvrir
tu es mon frère au reste toujours
ensemble c'est comme ça dans une famille
on qu'on se dépêche avant que les perdre
son pouvoir
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce vous êtes trop mimi dans
vos petites teignes de ninja
[Musique]
je suis sûr que ça peut s'arranger avec
du fric c'est quoi ce binz